so I want to read you this tweet by this
is a Washington Post reporter a
Washington Post journalist by the name
of Emily yarr she writes as Luke Combs
hit cover of Tracy Chapman's fast car
dominates the country charts it's
bringing up some complicated emotions in
fans and singers who know that Chapman
as a queer black woman would have an
almost zero chance at that achievement
herself now you might remember the song
Fast Car by Tracy Chapman because it was
a massive hit when it came out 30 some
odd years ago and Community notes the
fact-checking apparatus of Twitter made
note of that Fast Car by Tracy Chapman
was nominated for three Grammy Awards
including record of the year and song of
the year she won the four best female
pop vocal performance and Best New
Artist oh and she has seven other
nominations for Grammy Awards and two
other wins so the way that the
Washington Post frames this is because
that this white guy because what they're
saying is he's a white guy he's you know
country singer he must somehow also be a
white supremacist some of that nonsense
he's going to make a whole bunch of
money and win a whole bunch of awards on
this song uh this Tracy Chapman song and
she could oh but she did win a whole
bunch of awards and she became super
rich on it and then here's the best part
not only did she get do they get fact
checked Washington Post and that
ridiculous quote-unquote journalist but
even Tracy Chapman herself is speaking
out against this nonsense here uh is a
quote that she gave to people Chapman 59
spoke about the cover in an exclusive
statement to billboard writing I never
expected to find myself on the country
charts but I'm honored to be there
praising the new version by Combs 33 she
continued to the outlet I'm happy for
Luke and his success and grateful that
new fans have found and embraced fast
car so do you see what the machine does
with absolutely everything you had I
didn't know she was queer but okay
you've got a queer black woman who is a
multiple Grammy winner She's Got To Be A
Millionaire making tons of money still
on residuals and all of that stuff a
young country singer and this guy is uh
he's a major star right now he comes in
does a cover of it she gets residuals on
that stuff it's not like he's just
jacking the song and that's it
everybody's making money everybody gets
to hear more of her songs Washington
Post the machine the corporate press
machine decides to make it about race
and racism and opening up conversations
about queer
and it's all B
it's all Bs
[Music]